شو خطط الممولين السعوديين لهذا العام
والله انا لا استطيع ان اتحدث عن الممولين
اتحدث لان لكل صندوق خصوصياته لكن ص
ندوقنا احنا في عالمنا لانه احنا نعتبر
يعني ما يسمى
يعني ما اخفي عليك منبسط لما يكون الماكرو
كلايم شوي صعب لانه ما نستثمر فيه اليوم
فرص التخرج في سيكون من اربع الى خمس سنين
فبكون في زي ما تقولي
تحسن في في الوضع العام
فاحنا متحمسين جدا في هذه السنه
وينقلب السوق من سوق يعني
يصير في يعني
التقييمات بصير فيها انخفاض اصلا انت
كريادي بالتاسيس في هذا الوقت اصبح ارخص
لك الاجارات نزلت تكلفه التشغيل نزلت
واهتمام اكثر من الميادين اخرى
اكيد اكيد يعني مثل ما قلت لك احنا كصندوق
نبعد عن بعض
المجالات اللي التخرج فيها صعب يعني لا
تنسي ان الصندوق نحن ناخذ
من المستثمرين نتورك
على اساس انه هذا الريال سيصبح عشره او
100 ريال ان شاء الله
فهناك مجالات يعني طبيعي انها تميل او
تخرج فيها اسهل واكبر من مجالات اخرى
سنركز عليها ولكن يعني في سوقنا المجال
الشركات التقليديه الكثير الكثير يعني زي
ما بيقولوا
فيما استثمرنا في الفندق
مجالات كثيره نرى فيها ان الفشنسي عالي
جدا بحيث ان التكنولوجي ستطورها
تغيير المجتمع لانه البعض بتحدث عن انه
اصحاب الافكار في الميدان الصناعي عاده
بجد تمويل بسهوله اكثر من لدى الغرب لكن
في منطقتنا يتجه معظم التمويل للمشاريع
التي ليس لها قيمه مضافه غالبيه الشركات
اللي بتحصل على التمويل هي
بعمليات البيع الالكتروني اكثر منها افكار
ممكن ان تغير المجتمع
للامانه يعني هناك اهتمام كبير
في المنطقه
ونرى في المملكه العربيه السعوديه جهد
كبير على القطاع الصناعي بس بالنسبه يعني
صناديق راس المال الجريح نحن لا نستثمر في
هذا المجال لانه نموذج العمل مختلف هذه
الافكار الصناعيه تحتاج الى تمويل عالي
جدا في بدايه طريقه تحتاج الى جهات
وتشريعات صناديق راس المال الجريء يعني ما
هي قدها
بتعرف في مجال التكنولوجي انت وصديقك
تستطيع ان تقدموا وانتم في بيتكم انتم في
الكراج وانتم في الكافيه منتج قد يخدم
الكثير الكثير المشروع الصناعي يحتاج الى
تمويل عالي جدا شموع التقني في عالم
التكنولوجيا يحتاج الى طريق مكمل بادوار
مكمله من هو يعني البياع اللي وجد المشكله
من هو التقليص يترجم هذه الفيجن او هذه
الفكر الى كود ومن هو العمليات
بعد منتجك الاولي
فهو نموذج عمل يعني
انقبات بعض الصناديق ولكن هناك صناديق
يعني عندها اهميه اكثر او مربوطه في مراكز
بحث او مربوطه ممكن تستثمر في المشاريع
الصناعيه